one of the things that Allah says about
himself in the Quran and he says this
more than one time in Chapter 3 of the
Quran verse 54 it says that he is the
best of all deceivers the best of all
schemers the best of all connivers the
Arabic phrase
is that word Mak if you look at any
Arabic lexical Source means someone who
is a Shyer a caniver a trickster a
deceiver there is no way that here we go
we have the video of some shamon lying
to his followers and uh just before I
start with the refuting and exposing the
the lies and the double standard and the
hypocrisy of some shamon let us
understand the the meaning of deception
all right in the Quran Allah always
restricts because what is deception
firstly there's two type of deception
and plotting there's a blame worthy one
and a praiseworthy one the blame worthy
when you try to deceive innocent people
when you try to deceive um vulnerable
people when you try to deceive righteous
people because the person who wants to
deceive people he thinks he's very smart
and he's too uh wise and he he's too
powerful and he's because he think no
one's able to recognize his a plan so so
that's why in the Quran Allah always
restricts it deceive those who try to
deceive people because Allah showing the
this deceiver that Allah is all powerful
so you trying to deceive innocent people
and vulnerable people and righteous
people Allah would send your own
deception and your own plot against you
and this is which is praise worthy the
blame worthy one when you try to deceive
the innocent people vulnerable people
and righteous people let alone the
prophets so that if this is clear then
we move on to the next point which
is in the Bible clearly there's many
passages where where God is deceiving
righteous people for example in Jeremiah
he says here clearly Jeremiah 27 as you
can see the screen behind me you
deceived me Lord and I was deceived
deceived you overpowered me and
prevailed so why God deceived him
because God was powerful to deceive who
Jeremiah Jeremiah is a prophet and this
is a blame where deception which we re
reject God does not deceive His prophets
because the Old Testament is full of
hatred against righteous and the
prophets of God and against God himself
all right the other one I'm going to
show you again to show you the Christian
Missionary they're not out there to
clarify the truth and to call people to
the truth rather they're out there to
turn people away from the truth even
they will make up a lies even they would
they will criticize something which go
against their own scripture for the sake
of turning people away from the truth
let me show you another passage where
God is deceiving here we go read this
and if the prophet be deceived when he
had spoken a thing I the Lord have
deceived that Prophet so now the
Christians they cannot say no what his
name was wrong Jeremiah was wrong for
saying God deceived him now God himself
saying he deceives and let us lay down a
foundation in the Bible said Satan
deceives and likewise God deceives so
which one is more powerful in deceiving
who's the the best deceiver if you say
Satan then Satan is more powerful than
God if you say God then you do agree
with us in one aspect but we disagree
with you that God deceive righteous and
a prophet of his because as we have
mentioned there's two type of uh
deceiving and uh plotting praiseworthy
and blameworthy in the Bible you have
the blameworthy one and yet you want to
speak and guess Islam some shamon have
some shame please let us bring let me
bring you another uh passage from the
Bible where God encouraging an angel to
receive a king let us read here in the
Bible God is asking the Lord asked who
will deceive Ahab so that will go and be
killed at ramoth some of the Angels said
one thing and others said something
ghost until a spirit stepped forward
approached the Lord and said I will
deceive him how the Lord asked the
spirit replied I will go and make all of
ab's prophets say was a lie the Lord
said go and deceive him you will succeed
there so in the Bible you have Jeremiah
saying God deceived him likewise God
saying he deceived the prophet likewise
God encouraging people to deceive so how
dare you Sam shamun trying to criticize
the Quran or Allah the creator of
everything again to conclude my video by
calling the Christians to come to the
true teaching of God and leave the Bible
which is full of lies and blameworthy
deception and I'm not rejecting
everything in the Bible by the way by
the Bible you can see the writers have
deep hatred against God and against His
prophets and Messengers and Jesus and
Moses and all the prophets that are are
mighty men who are free from the lies
and the slander of the writers of the
Bible and I pray to Allah the creator of
everything to guide you to the truth Pro